c'est un véritable bain de foule qui
attendait bruno valentin plus de 2500
personnes ont assisté à son ordination
la cathédrale saint-louis de versailles
quelques jours avant de fêter son 47e
anniversaire l'ancien curé de montigny
voisins le bretonneux devient
officiellement évêque auxiliaire de
versailles c'est un grand moment de joie
cet après midi pour les catholiques d
évident mais pas seulement il y avait
aussi des représentants des musulmans
des juifs avec des élus qui étaient là
et on a vraiment partagé la même joie
c'est un moment d'entousiasme sssa
d'abord le souvenir que j'en garderai
dans un contexte sensible pour l'église
catholique bruno valentin aura la charge
d'épauler l'évêque de versailles
monseigneur aumônier dans
l'administration du diocèse un
territoire qui s'étend sur l'ensemble
des yvelines il est le seul à occuper
cette fonction d'évêque auxiliaire en
ile de france
il ya beaucoup à faire je vais continuer
avec lui et et avec plus de
d'enthousiasmé encore et comme si
j'avais plus d'énergie dans le public
des curés et fidèle que bruno valentin a
côtoyé lors de ses passages à trappes
château ou encore montini voisin chinois
pour le diocèse
c'est vraiment ça va être un nouvel élan
pour diocèse et c'est une joie qu'on
partage avec tous seraient c'est une
très belle cérémonie très priante est
vraiment entouré de tous les prêtres du
diocèse c'est une cérémonie super mais
là on a vraiment on est heureux d'être
chrétien la communauté chrétienne de
trappes était très représentée
aujourd'hui pendant cette messe
d'ordination voilà on n'a pas oublié il
sera resté
à l'écouté de chacun et est très simple
dans ces rapports monseigneur bruno
valentin va rencontrer prochainement la
personne à l'origine de sa nomination le
pape françois à rome